là là je veux bien folle à la cdec vous
avez montré vraiment qu'on a des gens
qui sont légitimes dans cette émission
que ça bosse et laeticia hallyday sa com
est elle sincère ou intéressés voilà on
va tenter d'analyser de répondre à cette
question là on sait que le 19 octobre
prochain en que dans quelques jours les
fans à moi les fans de johnny hallyday
vont découvrir l'album posthume ça
s'appelle mon pays c'est l'amour et
c'est laeticia hallyday qui vous fait
parler aussi parce qu'on sait qu'elle va
avoir les droits de cet album pour
l'instant c'est même elle qui est et
codirectrice artistique et qui s'en
occupe un petit peu ça va qu'elle
n'avait jamais jamais accepté de parler
elle était restée à sa bartels et
passait ses vacances
elle a donné aucune interview et là le
point point voilà c'est vrai qu'elle a
accepté d'approuver les interviews qui
étaient faites dans la presse a
complètement été délivrée par l'avocat
enfin je pense qu'elle confrères sont
d'accord avec moi franchement c'était le
cas tu as mangé
alors justement qu'on vend pas et bien
de la bresse que la com et sincère oui
ou non j'aimerais que vous commenciez
avec des oui ou non la pancarte comme ça
on le saura ce que vous en pensez
oui elle est comme dans 4 il n'y a pas
de wii non il ne l'a pas vu venir la
question des noms mais je peux pas être
légitime à tout moment je peux pas
l'avoir
non je peux pas attaquer même pas du
tout jamais tu dis non à leur bébé tu
mathieu non mais y'a pas encore un vrai
savoir pourquoi parce que jean pascal
chaumeil réponse d'un public qui connaît
pas tous les deux ce qui est derrière
donc c'est intéressant de savoir mais à
partir du moon alors que marley à partir
du moment où on parlait de communication
forcément il ya quelque chose de pas
sincère là dedans puisque tout est
forcément dans le but de passer un
message à son public tout cas il ya
forcément c'est pas c'est pas honnête à
100% vous savez bien quand vous donnez à
une interview mais faites attention à ce
que vous dites donc partant là j'entends
que la liste par exemple que là on a vu
sur bfm que cet été elle a accepté
je ne juge pas mais qu'elle accepte et
on va le voir dans my tho sur bfm
qu'elle a accepté qu'une caméra qui
viennent à filmer sur la tombe de johnny
hallyday juste avant voilà de retard et
c'est sincère ou pas sincère regardez
c'est à la nuit tombée qu'elle aime
honorer son homme comme elle dit
entouré de jade joy et de quelques
proches assise au pied de la tombe
scintillante la famille écoute des
titres de johnny échanges
[Musique]
on pleure on rit on le célèbre no confie
laeticia hallyday
laeticia hallyday ne reviendra pas sur
la tombe de son mari avant la toussaint
dans quelques semaines c'est en français
est attendu pour la sortie de l'album
posthume de johnny hallyday voilà alors
ap en danger pouvait que c'est bon parce
que tu devais excusez moi j'adore johnny
s'est bien gardée notamment que ça s'est
mise en scène ses indics
qu'est ce que vous en prenez ça peut
paraître mis en scène parce que c'est
vrai que dire de tous les soirs sur une
tombe d'allumer des bougies de mettre de
la musique d'avoir les deux petites
filles avec soi puisque les amis et
d'être à genoux et pleurer ça semble
bizarre
sauf qu'elle a fait tous les soirs cet
été elle a pas fait la seule fois où il
y avait des caméras de bfm
tous les soirs ils font ça avec tous les
amis qu'ils étaient tous les soirs et
oui absolument
ces photos et coach a des fans et fans
sont avec eux étaient chaque foyer un
décor nouveau avec des fleurs à un peu
particulière avec ses mises en scène du
deuil si on veut oui mais elle a
peut-être enfin l'ex team son deuil un
peu comme elle veut dans ce cimetière
cassé bout d'ailleurs et marc ailleurs
cela que de sa vraie communication va
commencer quand elle va venir à paris là
il falloir qu'elle parle elle va faire
un jt en direct sur tf1
le plan veut dire un plan média juste en
un mot c'est quoi elle fait 4-4 alors
fait que trois finalement là que 3 elle
devait or elle devait faire trois le
faire le 20 heures de tf1 la veille de
la sortie de l'album en direct à leur
calvaire à la base elle devait le faire
enregistrer parce qu'elle préférait mais
là il va devoir y aller en direct elle
va faire le même jour une soirée d'été à
vous d'en match 300 mais le lendemain
elle sera chez fogel le soir rtl soir
côté fogiel week end les finales et sept
autres qui disent comme ça je protège
les images encore une fois je vous dis
tout ce qu'on entend et tout ça ce que
sur les mauvaises langues bas que grosso
modo le voile alalala fait le deuil
assez rapidement et que maintenant deux
reprises et los angeles voilà avec des
tenues un peu légère lorsqu'elle doit
être noir on aurait vu avec une voiture
à 300 mille balles juste derrière lui
c'est pas signer wen la musique est
originaire et où elle a des photos sans
soutien gorge alors mais je sais pas est
ce qu'il faut attaquer à la presse à
vous préparer une autre et en omettant
les idées ou est-ce que c'est elle qui a
peur de ça comme ça quand elle sort elle
sait qu'elle va être photographiés donc
c'est eux qui décident de ne pas mettre
son soutien gorge
voilà mais il faut arrêter mais
justement ça c'est vous cet automne
n'ont alors pas du tout c'est à los
angeles je reconnaisse et los angeles
oui absolument moi j'en suis en fait
bizarrement j'en suis revenue de
laeticia hallyday c'est à dire qu'au
début j'avais un peu tendance un peu
comme tout le monde à dire que c'était
la vilaine marâtre qu'avait tenu la mort
johnny lui signe un peu son son chèque
et puis et puis avec le temps des
passionnants un peu tout ça je me suis
rendu compte que je pense que on a l'air
de découvrir que johnny hallyday était
un très mauvais homme d'affaires toute
sa vie il a fait des bourdes en affaires
et bien là il vient d'en faire une
magnifique une magnifique serre qu'il
est désiré de ces reproches à laetitia
ce qu'on peut reprocher à laëtitia
effectivement ça c'est des passionnés si
lui est mauvaise entame mauvaise hommes
d'affaires un homme qui veut qui dit à
sa femme qu'il compte déshériter ses
deux enfants aînés le rôle d'une femme
c'est de dire non on ne fait pas ça mais
elle a tout à fait finie elle a
totalement sous estimé et et pascal vs
angeles elle se fait conseiller par des
avocats américains qui ne connaissent
pas johnny donc ils n'ont pas idée de
l'affect que porte le pays pour johnny
pour ses premiers jo ton père en tant
que ça vous choque là que maintenant
elle parle au moment où l'album sort que
l'album bad et de la promo de faire la
promo
il attendait johnny lui a demandé de
défendre
elle porte son nom de lieu de défendre
et c'est sa volonté alors après moi je
pense que le responsable de tout ce
bordel en fait c'est c'est johnny et
s'est lui-même uniquement johnny
hallyday on est d'accord
elle a 40 ans excusez moi c'est pas que
johnny c'est son épouse était banal à 40
ans il savait très bien ce qu'il faisait
et avait matière à dire à johnny écoute
tout ça va créer un problème en france
donne une petite partie même petit à
thézan aux aînés et le problème sera
réglé
ex palais pas franchement franchement
c'est un copain elle est pas tout
mélanger bonjour à l'assemblée nationale
c'est ce public j'aimerais pourquoi tu
pour que tu me dis je ne peux pas
l'attaquer parce que parce que parce que
pour moi si elle avait fait de bonnes
choses et je reviens ce que vous disiez
elle aurait dû dire écoutez vous voulez
l'argent de l'album prenait l'argent pas
d'histoires de famille et elle sauvait
sur son mari là on a l'impression ses
gardes et les sous sénat avant que
j'avais bien ou pas g j'ai toujours un
peu mal mais je je je regardais
naturellement et comme ça maintenant jr
voilà pourquoi j'ai un regard du gtr
gérer comme on l'a attaqué quand tu
perds quelqu'un de cher logiquement tu
penses à quelqu'un de cher si l'amour
c'est une histoire d'argent pour moi
c'est pas de l'amour mais c'est un désir
d enfant tu écoutais voulait le pognon
prenez le mais c'est moi tremblay à
faire le deuil de mon mari c'est pas se
brûler mais elle s'est passé enfants
s'est penché giraud continuer ma
compagne aujourd'hui elle considère mes
réponses comme les sièges moi j'ai fait
un libre johnny sept ans alors je t'aime
avoir terminé avec catherine café un
livre sur johnny fait après sa tournée
où il est tombé malade il est tombé
malade effet - los angeles quand il a
failli mourir los angeles
il a eu très peur en se réveillant de
réaliser qu'il n'est pas d'argent que
les deux petites filles et qu'il est
terminée qu'elle pas un sou de pour la
famille donc il a eu de cesse depuis
huit ans jusqu'à sa mort de reconstituer
ses finances d'acheter des maisons pour
protéger sa petite fille sa part d'un
très bon sentiment et je parle d'un bon
sentiment